bonjour wilfried cinar bonjour je livory
alors vous êtes candidat à ducos vous
avez 56 temps vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet de la ville de ducos du maire de
ducos et vous allez conduire la liste
dynamique du co 16 wilfried cina
qu'est ce que vous venez faire dans
cette galère pourquoi vous présentez
alors je vais déjà dire ou un jeu aux
téléspectateurs de la martinique et de
du conseil herman alors en fait la
politique c'est quand même une chose de
très passionnante et sa gelée découvert
en 1982 était jeune j'avais 20 ans quand
j'ai croisé la route d'un certain
monsieur qui était maire de l'époque
maurice lui joseph de gays qui j'étais
militant associatif
j'ai commencé à militer dans le
mouvement associatif depuis l'âge de 16
ans et quand j'ai commencé ce péché
c'était la fête du quartier
il m'a repéré je dirais puisqu'il m'a
appelé m'a demandé comment t'appelles-tu
j'ai dit que je m'appelle wilfried cina
que fais tu ça se passe au loin d'autres
de l'année 1990 jeudi je pars le mois
prochain en métropole pour pouvoir faire
les études d'expert comptable sur
intégrer une école et il me dit j'ai un
monde qui en france qu amendé vivent et
qui se réchauffe passe me voir demain
matin en mairie
c'est à dire je passe le voir lundi
matin et quand je passe le roi il m'a
dit ben oui mais je t'ai dit fait venir
au travail et c'est de là qu'a commencé
d'histoire puisque
je me suis bien rendu compte que si ce
monsieur monsieur longuet qui était amer
avec la posture qu'on le connaissait m'a
demandé de venir de ne pas partir c'est
qu'il y avait probablement quelque chose
à faire effectivement il me dit du
kwassa besoins de ses enfants et depuis
je suis donc engagé dans non seulement
dans le mouvement associatif mais aussi
politiquement puisque à côté de lui
j'ai appris à mener des combats
politiques on a tout d'accord je parlais
de galère et vous savez très bien vos
proches parlent de galère parce
qu'aujourd'hui la vesle de ducos est
très endetté le rapport de la chambre
régionale des comptes est accablant
aujourd'hui la capacité financière de la
ville et resterai de voir même certains
mâles parle en fait certaines mauvaises
langues diraient inexistante
qu'est ce que vous dites vous alors
quand j'entends ça je veux dit mais il y
a une chose qui est très facile et on
s'en aperçoit tout le temps
régulièrement c'est d'être debout sur le
bord de la route
critiquer matin midi soir soit un moment
donné dire je me retrousse les manches
et je viens mettre la main à la pâte
vous êtes en train de dire que le maire
jalons démence et a eu raison
je ne vais pas dire qu'il a raison mais
je vais dire qu'il a assumé la mission
de mer ce qu'on attend de mer c'est
ainsi qu'on va embaucher un maire ne
doit pas être quelqu'un de fragile
il y a un problème de société on le dit
tous les jours matin midi soir j'écoute
la presse je lis la presse je le vois
matin midi soir tout le monde par les
jeunes partent et par 3 me l'ont dit les
homicides volontaires y en a 20
20 dans l'année la prison est trop petit
mais qu'on le veuille ou non aujourd'hui
l'état dit quoi aidez moi à rembourser
la dette que j'ai alors je parle du
possible que le maire la commune quelle
qu'elle soit c'est sept ans d'idylle a
qui jouent le rôle d'amortisseur social
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est le maire
qui est à proximité en ré et à proximité
des réalités des difficultés qu'il ya
sur un territoire et donc partir de ce
principe la challenge league ans et a
dit je prends mes responsabilités quels
sont vos programmes il nous reste à
peine 30 secondes
quels sont les grands axes de votre
programme pour ces élections alors la
première dimanche va être de faire une
restructuration profonde de
l'administration municipale
vous allez licencié parce que demandé
par la somme régionale des comptes alors
il faut pas venir ajouter de la
souffrance ou la souffrance en tout cas
moi non licenciés non mais nous allons
réorganiser et est donc après faire une
diabolique de la situation donc un état
des lieux rétrospectif et prospectif
voir comment on peut avancer on
s'organise pour avancer puisque nous
venons avec un projet de ville 2020 2030
nous donc de manière à faire en sorte
que les ducaux c'est profite du mieux
vivre de leur territoire
wilfrid sina je vous remercie merci
monsieur lévi
[Musique]